this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Jenny thank you I'll try and
live up to that wonderful introduction I
feel a little bit over empowered by that
yeah so I am a microbial ecologist
actually started out my life as a marine
microbial ecologist and applying the
rules of how bacteria communicate with
each other and with their environment
how they sense things to understanding
how they do that in many other
ecosystems what is a really amazing time
to be a microbial ecologist is the one
that a few times in history where people
have actually taken us really deadly
seriously the first time was probably in
the late 19th century where they found
out bacteria could kill you and now they
find out the bacteria can make people
healthy they're really starting to pay
attention and what's great is that the
horticultural world is starting to pay
attention as well and the fact that the
bacteria that colonized plants and live
on the outsides of plants and inside the
plants actually may be playing a role in
the health of the plant now obviously
this isn't anything new in fact if
anything the agricultural world has led
the world of science in utilizing and
understanding how bacteria play a role
in the health of plants you know you
can't look at nitrogen fixation any
other way but it's been incredibly
important for us as researchers to
understand how all of the ecological
interactions that go on inside the
ecosystem which is a plant how they play
a role in the health and productivity
and development of these organisms so
something to do with plants and microbes
I changed my title I did found the earth
microbiome project around five years ago
this was a to catalog microbial
diversity in as many environments as we
could find with my colleagues Rob Knight
and Janet Johnson we we really tried to
push this forward as a as an opportunity
to look into ecosystems and build out a
repository to help us understand how
many organisms there were their
potential functions and how they were
interacting with the world around them
on a global scale so you know as was
famous for Chicago we had most small
plans it was a very big undertaking we
were very ambitious at the beginning
and then we started to ramp back our
ambitions as we found out quite how
difficult it was to get people to share
their samples and share their data we
initially thought what everybody will
want to have the microbiome sequence of
course because the microbiome is awesome
and then we quickly realized that people
were not necessarily as excited about
sharing all of their carbon data and you
know all the ancillary data that we
thought was just ancillary data which
turned out to be people's PhD theses and
publications they weren't quite as
willing to share that upfront as we
thought they would be and and so we
started to scale back our ambitions but
to date with over the 400 collaborators
we have we processed around 50,000
samples for 16s ribosomal RNA sequencing
about half of those for about four 18s
ribosomal sequencing and then a
smattering of those for shotgun meta
genomics as we slowly burnt through our
financial supplies and contacts these
represent over 50 large-scale biomes a
biome being like open ocean or Prairie
soil you know and there's around sixty
six billion sequences in this database
with a little over twenty seven million
bacterial tax are identified and the
data analysis is occurring in a public
forum all of this data is made publicly
available immediately
we haven't actually published any of the
results of this study other people have
been publishing it for us and as I was I
was talking to Terry on the wave from
the airport I was saying well you know
we'd be quite happy if someone wanted to
take all this data and actually publish
it because it's a pain in the ass to try
and analyze it so that would be that'd
be fantastic there is a pay people
coming out have been utilizing some of
this data to try and understand how many
species there might be on earth and to
predict that number of species and there
are exciting studies coming out that
utilizing this data to understand by
Geographic patterns the pattern
associations with different climatic
variables etc etc but I'm going to talk
a little bit about how we've utilized
some of these data and other studies in
order to try and derive some kind of
large-scale ecological understanding of
the interactions between plants and
bacteria and over soil systems so one of
the first ones we did as part of the EMP
was work with Rebecca McCully and
Fiera on modeling utilizing microbial
community systems to model how bacterial
communities varied across a range of
prairie conditions in the Midwest so
collecting samples from tall relic sort
of our relic tall grass prairie sites
meant creeping into basic graveyards in
the dead of night and taking soil cores
and into the disused railway lines
anywhere that hadn't really been used
for agricultural activity since around
1850 this meant civil war graveyards
we basically collected samples from
those because they were the least
contaminated by agricultural activity
Illinois has lost about 98 to 99% of its
Prairie I mean you know that's a
remarkable degradation of a natural
biological environment in one that you
know we we bitterly complain with other
countries try and you know agricultural
eyes their lands in you know in the
destruction of the Amazon rainforest but
what we did to one of our primary
biological environments nearly
comprehensively destroyed it but we
utilize this information to look at the
microbial communities in different sites
around this this from the extent of this
Prairie system and then we interpolated
and extrapolated beyond those points to
understand how climatic variables that
exist now correlate with the position of
those microbes along with plant
variables and then we hindcast that back
to around 1842 when the Prairie was
complete so the product the extent of
the Midwest Gras tall grassland Prairie
system had a distribution that looks
something like that by mapping our
association between climactic variables
and plant distribution patterns we were
able to identify the predicted relative
abundances of organisms like the Veruca
microbial phylum across that system and
generate some kind of predictive
understanding of the distribution of
that organism now why is that important
well
Veruca microbial are hard to culture the
entire phylum has very few cultured
representatives in our databases they
flourish where carbon nitrogen ratios
are very high because they they don't
necessarily do so well when you have a
lot of knights
they're good at carbon metabolism and
they're good at activating resources
which can be used by certain types of
plants and so when soils are turned over
to agriculture and you get an increase
in nitrogen you see these things
disappearing very quickly and we're very
interested in trying to identify ways to
restore these Prairie ecosystems and we
you know very well to go in and you know
rip out all of the existing vegetation
and just plant a load of new seeds and
that that's proven to be very effective
in certain systems but we're also keen
to say well how can we create stable
ecosystems how can we rebuild carbon
processes and organic matter pools
within these systems which support the
the autonomous preservation of that
environment and to do that we had to
understand those bacteria which was
significantly related to that and more
importantly their functional diversity
and their capability of supporting
carbon and nitrogen turnover in these
environments right so this may seem a
little bit like oh wow they do
time-travelling Statistics to predict
what things that like 150 years ago
would be do but if you yeah and it does
look like that but but that's not
necessarily the be-all and end-all what
we're really trying to do is capture the
system and understand how that system
varies I understand what perturbs it
what leads to its stability so that we
can try and recreate it not just in our
computers but in the field and so
working with other researchers around
the Midwest and on the East Coast we're
now trying to implement some of the work
that we've done here in small plots and
actually build out new systems where we
where we have restored Prairie sites
we've also been working on this in
different contexts but across climactic
gradients so this is work we're doing
with my colleagues in national Chinese
Academy of Sciences trying to understand
the differentiation in forest ecosystems
across a climatic gradient along the
east coast of China so work
collaboration between our labs we took
samples along this gradient a hundred
and ten soil samples from both natural
undisturbed forests across this gradient
and then basically an
the diversity of archaea bacteria and
fungi this paper is in submission I'll
show you a lot of data today and I
that's not yet been published so you can
you could feel free to peer-review
critique it as much as you want but I've
always been very upfront about
presenting the data that we we are
already working on I think it's
important to get feedback from the
community and also if you can analyze it
faster than we can then go for it that'd
be cool but so you know we see a lot of
crenarchaeota we see a lot of operator
bacteria no big deal we see a lot of
ascomycota but we do see amazing bio
Geographic variants and we can map a
model that variants to large-scale
network patterns to identify strong
correlative interaction space between
different kingdoms of organisms so every
dot here is a bacterial o2u every green
dot is a eukaryotic o2 you blue is
archaea red black line sorry A+ and the
red interactions you can't see many of
those but I can't even see them and I'm
looking at close there's some there are
negative connotations this again just
looks like a massive of networked
information but by teasing apart the
topology of these networks we can
actually start to understand how some
climactic variables can lead to
differentiation in Co Association
patents so all these connections are
strong and significant only those with
the Spearman's of greater than not 0.7
are actually identified in this network
structure each size of each node portion
all to the relative bumps of the
organism and there there's 66,000
associations among 3,000 microbial owe
to you okay so nearly four thousand
ninety percent of these interactions are
global and only ten are region specific
so there are inherent structures within
forest ecosystems across the eastern
seaboard of China which are globally
distributed no matter what we see in the
system suggesting that there's niche
specificity within a forest ecosystem
irrespective of the climactic region but
the inherent variants in the system
there's ten percent of these
interactions which are region specific
that's what yields climatic range
specificity and that climactic
Rheinsberg
50 is what's interesting to us because
by understanding the variance between
regions we can start to understand what
makes an ecosystem important in that
environment because those organisms may
be important to these system ecology so
looking at this if we look at how we
interpret that network topology the
connectivity of the network is greater
we get more connections more significant
interactions between bacteria archaea
and eukaryotes up in the in the northern
region compared to the southern region
we get greater precipitation in the
south it's a semi tropical environment
and we believe that this greater
precipitation needs to decrease niche
differentiation essentially you're
getting more moisture connectivity in
the environment moisture connectivity
allows microbes to move out of their
individual pockets and interact more on
a global scale indirectly through
metabolites transfer and directly
through movement and so you get an ink
decrease in the in the specific niche
connectivity between organisms and an
increase in a broad scale
characterization of Network space so
lower precipitation north induces his
strong niche differentiation basically
organisms clustering down in their
little niches disassociated from other
organisms which may be a millimeter away
on another organic mass matter particle
and that that niche differentiation is a
globally attributable trait in a study
I'm not going to talk about in detail
and I'm not going to mention apartment
right now when I am gonna mention it but
at the hospital microbiome project we in
this study we we followed a hospital
environment ten patient rooms to nursing
stations for 365 consecutive days
cataloging all of the patients on three
body surfaces and all of the staff and
all of the environments within the
hospital some 50 different surfaces
including air and water and we look to
the bacterial community structure across
all of these environments we see that
people share more bacteria between each
other including patients to staff and
staff to patients and staff to staff
when the environment it has more
humidity basically when bacteria have
the Cape
surviving outside the body we see a
definitive increase in sharing what's
interesting and I again I'm Toni
unpublished data which is coming in
review but just tell anyone we don't see
an increase in disease burden in that
population so this increase in microbial
sharing isn't leading to an increase in
horizontal sorry so hospital acquired
infections
it's just distributing microbes on a
bigger scale that if anything we see a
small depression and we can talk about
what that means until the cows come home
but moisture is very important it allows
for connectivity allows for increased
activity and movement of organisms
between sites
I am very tangental as well if I go off
on a to we're to track there's someone
throw something at me and I'll drag it
back on to what I was talking about
before
all right so utilizing this information
we can start to build out
intercontinental and transcontinental
understanding of microbial community
structure and what it means in a system
so this is the Tibetan Plateau and North
America collecting samples and transics
and dotted samples around areas and
transects around the Tibetan Plateau
across climatic regions we can start to
interpolate and build maps of microbial
community structure across these systems
and link them into climactic variables
in an attempt to try and predict how
these systems respond to climate
changing environmental systems so so
this is the Tibetan Plateau starting in
1904 now in 1925 1930 with annual
averages and the shift in microbial
community structure will be to diversity
across the whole system as we move
across a deck herbs or a century of
climactic variants what we see in this
pretty picture is a is a significant
change in the I'm just play again so you
can see it when I'm talking about it
it's a significant change in the
community fluctuation in the in the
differentiation of microbial community
as parts of the system become
destabilized due to increasing
temperatures as parts the system become
highly productive due to increasing
carbon dioxide and as agricultural
activity takes over in the
in the latter part of the 20th century
um yes because I went back there I'm
English I'm a time traveler have you not
watched up to him so it's it's its hind
casting we actually have pretty good
climactic records back to 1910 prior to
1910 they don't exist there are weather
stations present in parts of Tibet back
then and they were first part by the
British and then and then later by some
of the French and then the Chinese but
the the system's been reasonably well
monitored and we have good records for
global climate variables at degrees of
resolution for pretty much the whole
globe back to a certain level mostly
interpolated from existing data and you
can you prove me wrong maybe I'm not
trying to predict what happened
beforehand I'm trying to understand if
anything what the relationship is
between microbial communities d
stability or stability between years and
climactic variables and because I can
even within a five-year grant I can only
get five years of that data I have to
try and predict outside the bounds but
you can use this to make predictions
about what's happening now with you know
at a fine scale if you understand what
the long-term trends might be so again
this is just a pretty picture but
underlying it is sort of fundamental
statistical model which can help us to
extrapolate and predict beyond our
measures so in here what's interesting
is the microbial community structure of
present-day Tibet is best predicted
though I'm talking to you alone
understand here that's predicted by the
the climactic variables in between 1968
and 1972 so if we look at the others
which again there's a bit of weird right
if we look at the climate in 1968 1972
that is the climate which best
correlates with what we observe in
current day Tibet and the same is
actually equally true for for North
America and if we take that as a
variable predictive algorithm it means
that we can predict if nothing changed
on earth for the next 30 years taking
today's climate we can predict what
should see the system stabilized - in
about 30 years time so on that basis
this is obviously Tibetan North America
this is the current richness and in over
the next thirty years if we believe that
climate has this relationship between
time and microbial community structure
we'll see a significant shift in
richness basically the systems have
become increasing richness juice of
destabilization a community structure
and reduction in abundance of certain
key organisms but whereas most of Tibet
will show a regionally homogeneous
predictive capability the the North
American coast will show a highly
heterogeneous response variable but
still majority will increase in in
richness and if you see the similarity
between what happens in northern Canada
and what happens in this other basically
our semi Arctic zone they call Nepal the
third Pole on earth we see a similar
increase in richness due to a
destabilization of of the of the adapt
variables in the solar system obviously
this is highly linked to plants but what
we haven't done at all is use plants in
any of these calculations we would love
to but we don't have a lot of the data
what we do see is variance in the types
of bacteria that we find across these
different systems and we can record that
to plant inputs so in Tibet we'll see an
increase in our four Proteobacteria let
me qualify that statement we predict if
everything stays normal and there's no
inputs at all that will see a increase
in Alphabet of its here in a decrease in
North America okay
a further bacteria in both of these
systems in these soil systems show a
significant correlation to carbon
nitrogen ratio and therefore we believe
that this could be linked into and so
moisture and could be linked into a
distribution in the change in below
carbon inputs into this system right so
by changing below carbon inputs based on
changing a plant biodiversity and plant
structure we'll see a shift in the
microbial community again will be due
but at least we've got some kind of
understanding of the potential
implications and we're now trying to use
this to predict occurrences each year in
these systems but it's very broad scale
we're hoping to get much finer
resolution as we move forward with our
ability to classify the system okay
something totally different
nolo I know I know I was talking I was
talking with the guys working on a
reasoning earlier you know we start out
in the low I also love wine think it's
awesome and we were very interested in
the connectivity between above-ground
tissues in implants and what was
happening in the soil and trying to
understand the potential implications
for strain type variants and microbial
community structure and the graphic
variables and soil systems so number one
this is just a map if the dots are
closer together more similar the black
dots represent Oh to use hah okay sorry
the black dots represent bacterial taxa
and the the colored big dots represent a
sample and so what we've done is
basically taken all of the dots the
other ot use and the similarity and the
abundances of those o2 you starts to
drag together or pull apart individual
sample types so bulk soil and root zone
call the root zone it wasn't rhizosphere
it was just this soil around the roots
all Custer very closely together because
they're very similar environments and
then your root system so the riser plane
starts to differentiate significantly
from that and that you move up into
grapes and leaves and in yellow flowers
we see a significant differentiation but
you notice that the OT use that are
shared in the soil are also shared down
here there are lots and lots of these
lines connecting these green and yellow
plots down to the the yellow and so the
blue and red plots over here and so that
that immediately told us that that the
vast majority of OT use of bacterial tax
that we found up in the above-ground
tissues came from down here or what also
found down here if they didn't come down
there they came from their supplier some
other route a below ground you know you
see a significant differentiation in the
high-level functional strut community
structure of these communities the
Proteobacteria dominating those
above-ground systems and mostly
organisms which are good at dealing with
stressful environments if we if we look
at the types of
variables which drive differentiation in
these systems we see that the adapts are
very important particularly carbon
nitrogen ratio and pH pH was a very
interesting one for us we saw we looked
at different vineyards throughout a
vineyard vineyard region what's a
vineyard region called like a wineries
region whatever very what's called it
but place where there are lots of
vineyards and we looked at the same
strain of Merlot the same group - eco
type of Merlot across these different
vineyards and then catalogued how the
community structure changed across those
vineyards and we see pH is a big
variable that drives that because
different vineyards use different types
of organic fertilizer and inorganic
fertilizer to fertilize the soil and
while we saw impacts of carbon and and
and carbon nitrogen ratios as drivers
the pH induced in the different soils
was still a key driver which is known
and the interesting there was a
significant effect due to air
temperatures indicating a driver for the
microbial - are especially on the above
ground surfaces between 2011 and 2012 we
saw a significant differentiation in the
flowers and in the in the leaves between
the two annual time points suggesting
that a change in temperature could have
an impact upon what's happening to the
microbial population including in the
soil so these these the system variance
was being driven by solid Aphex and also
climactic variables changing tack again
I'm I'm switching around because I have
lots of stories to tell we this is all
very well and good understanding how
community structure differentiates
across these natural gradients but what
I'm most interested in is why why
certain bacterial organisms are finding
themselves co associated with this
environment and becoming abundant versus
this environment what is the Selective
pressure of driving those organisms to
do develop in that space how do they
evolve to adapt to that environment and
the only way to do that is to start to
rebuild the genomes of those organisms
from my perspective and look at the
evolutionary drivers in the trait
selection within those populations and
so we construct genomes on a large scale
from a typical meta-genome we can grab
lots of
different bacterial isolates from
different general in that system we can
grab viral genomes we can even grab some
RKL genomes and we can utilize that
information to build out metabolic
models which describe how those
organisms interact with each other and
with their environment so this is a
great example working in a soil system
with hydrochloric X and pollution so
this is a when you create lindane you
you have a pollutant which you throw
back into the soil and there's these
huge HTH dumps in certain countries
around the world they're illegal in a
lot of countries but they create a very
toxic environment and so by looking at
hch degradation in the microbial
community we can look at organisms we
can culture up and genome sequence and
we can map those to metagenomes we
collect from these environments and
utilizing that information we can
predict what the last common ancestor of
the extent population in the system
would have been and utilizing this
information it suggests that the
ancestor genotype well lacks just that
20% the genes in each subspecies were
absent in the answer so these these sub
species we see present in the system
have gained genetic material due to a
selective pressure driver from from the
pollution event the ancestor we we
predict is unable to grade h th and it
acquires the Lin genes to allow it to
degrade h CH from this transposon
mediated lateral gene transfer and we
can actually even isolate a lot of the
transposons and transposon
elements in the in the genes in the
genomes of these organisms and Co
associate them and they're nonsynonymous
synonymous ratio with the lindane read
lindane degrading regions and this helps
us to predict the functional capability
that organism and how it evolved that
capability dope yeah I know I understand
what you're thinking I've gone from the
entire planet and I've now assumed down
into one genome but looking across those
scales is really important and we can
also go even further when we dig down
into the metabolic capability of an
organism this is working work we did in
peat moss and looking at the Marquee
odor and thermal plasma thermal Cody
these long-chain fatty acids fires and
trophic interaction with methanogens and
what we've been able to do by taking the
genomes of these organisms and looking
at them across redox gradients in the
system we can identify the drivers which
allow these organisms to respire so the
we got anaerobic respiration with
fumarate as a terminal electron etc when
we when we look at thermal plasma to
another organisms which we had no genome
relatives in the system before we see
sulfite and organosulfur Nate reduction
as the driver for its capability to
respond so tablet electron acceptors are
depleted to very low levels in some of
these systems and yet anaerobic
respiration is really dominant still you
know as a key component and so why are
these these archaea particularly
abundant so looking you know we now
fumarate and organosulfur Nate are
important for respiration of the carbon
mineralized in these peatlands which
gives us an ability at the molecular
level to start to understand the
potential implications of changes in
this environment upon carbon
mineralization right and the
remineralization of components into the
biosphere and driving potential changes
in in climate systems so taking you know
I've gone from making spurious comments
about what happened in the 9th 1840s to
driving all the way down into the
potential metabolic interactions of an
organism with its environment and
linking those substrates between the two
is going to become increasingly
important in our ability to derive
appropriate accurate predictive climate
models from what we can understand of as
a system driver in in the soil
environment I was going to go to a new
study sorry I really like this one this
is a brand new one
I have no attention span you can
understand that from this so we really
interested invading plants mostly
because when we were working in long
tall grass prairies we see this
beautiful relationship between a stable
ecosystem and it's it's very stable but
highly sorry it's very very permanent
but highly unstable community structure
when we perturb that long
Prairie even an iota the system starts
to disassemble okay increase the
nitrogen by a small margin in the system
disassembled so we wanted to understand
well how do when a plant starts to
invade the system how does it influence
that below-ground microbial community
and what are the significant drivers and
what can we say about the the the legacy
of an invasion in terms of perturbing
our ability to restore that environment
back to what it was before so working we
got this multi billionaire in Chicago
who brought up a load of land in Montana
because he wanted to be a biologist when
he was a kid but his daddy said no and
he went into the city and he made a lot
of money and now he gets to play in his
sandbox you love those people only in
America can I find that kind of human I
love it so we get to play in his sandbox
and so he's basically trying to his
gambit is restore the ecosystem back to
the original tall grass prairie so he
brought up ten thousand acres of ranch
and set us with this task so initial
task is to try and understand why that
system needs to be restored so here we
have three gradients of cheatgrass NAT
wheeze and leafy spurge an invasion
gradient from high abundance of the
invader to absence and so all the
intensive purposes is native Prairie I'm
going up to an invaded plot obviously
for the plants you do see a very strong
gradient between the plant biodiversity
and and the and the invasion plot when
when you get a highly invaded plot you
have a sort of highly invaded plot you
have a highly differentiated plant
biodiversity beat a diversity pattern
bacteria show a similar but not quite as
for a bust trend apart from apart from
in the the leafy spurge OS killer car
member might be leave his photo
cheatgrass but either way this shows a
very strong gradient the fungi show a
much stronger gradient in response their
beasts adversity pattern shows much
stronger gradient in response to the
invasion pattern and so we can start to
say that yes invasion does have an
impact upon the microbial community
structure in that system we can
differentiate that from well maybe
this invasion area was priests supposed
to be good for those plants because of
these microbial community structures or
some kind of adapt variable by looking
at this over time so we in Covent Garden
experiments we've planted up these
systems with invasives one year after
planting and there's no real significant
difference between the microbial
community structure in either the native
environment in green cheatgrass in red
knapweed in blue or spurge in yellow so
one year was not enough in these systems
to derive any kind of spatial
differentiation or pattern but after
three years the system starts to arrange
and we're now pushing this on but we've
only just got three years about eight
weeks ago so what we citing to see now
is at least at least for a nap weed and
first spurge we start and see
significant clustering of those
populations the microbial communities in
the blow ground systems around that
invasion system so the system starts to
show consistent shifts in chemistry and
microchemistry I'm not showing the
chemistry here and we believe that these
modifications are saw properties
probably driven by increases in carbon
inputs into the soil due to predatory
release of the of the invader in its
because no noddy's native habitats
anymore reinforce the dominance of the
invader making sure those invasions are
difficult to remove we think
unfortunately for our billionaire
playboy that it's very very hard to
remove some of these invaders nigh
impossible once they get to a certain
level ie their legacy on that soil
system might be might be unattainable
unless you go through an incredibly
dramatic ecosystem structural difference
donor
finally fertilization reduces bacterial
so I just wanted to point this out we do
a lot of work with groups in Africa
trying to understand I've never been to
Africa than myself others who - Rebecca
early but I'd love to go but we are
trying to take some of this data and put
it into a more translational framework
so that people growers especially you
can start to utilize it and so trying to
understand how differential land use
strategies such as rotations and
fertiliser combinations can be
used to increase functional capacity so
utilizing numerical models and
statistical models we can start to
understand the potential implications of
differential land management strategies
for improving productivity for some of
the nine hundred million poor people who
are using agriculture as their
subsistence mechanism okay
on a completely different note how much
longer have I got so now I've got to be
strict seven more minutes okay you are
currently sitting in a bill Tico system
right every single one of you is
emitting 38 million bacterial cells into
your environment every hour you're all
becoming more microbiology similar but
people who are sitting closer to each
other are becoming more microbial
actually similar than the people sitting
further away if you are physically
interacting you'd be increasing that
degree of similarity and this
environment is the environment where
we're all growing up okay where we as a
species unless you grew up on a farm or
you grew up in the Amazon rainforest I
don't know there might be some people in
the room that fit that description the
vast majority of us grew up in a
twentieth-century home or some of you
21st century home and that has
significantly altered your microbial
interaction compared to what your
ancestors experienced your ancestors
probably experienced the more agrarian
lifestyle interacting with the cows and
the pigs not playing on their iPads but
actually living outside and working
outside even as young children and that
increased their microbial biodiversity
of their bodies well but when your child
is brought back from that from the
hospital and lives in this environment
where it's consistently cleaned and made
quite sterile this architectural II
artificial system is altering their
microbial profile but enough about
health we started off this whole gambit
on health but I wanted to talk a little
bit about microbial forensics it's a new
track of mine something I'm very
interested in we started out by doing a
study for the sloan foundation on the
home microbiome we found among other
things that families we could look at
the bacterial community on say the
floors and the doorknobs et cetera and
we could with a high degree of accuracy
predict which family belonged to which
home based on the bacteria they left
behind in their home because those 38
million microbial cells you're shedding
your microbial cloud these are microbial
fingerprint
in your home right nice this is this is
each one of these shows a particular
surface focus on the kitchen counter
these are three people a grown-up child
living with his parents and the three
dogs if we look at the kitchen counter
person three their microbiome is the
predominant influencer of that
environment the predominant source for
bacteria found in that environment she's
the mother of the family is no gender
bias here but you can see that she
actually went away for a little while
person one goes away here and he's
microbiome disappears that's the red one
but person plots them to who is the
father of the home he's microbiome
suddenly became dominant in the kitchen
when his wife went away for a couple of
days so it's a lot the kitchen floor was
dominated by dog bacteria and we think
this is obviously important because dogs
are significantly contributing as well
as the mothers bacteria are having a
sniffing troll because her cloud is
depositing bacteria there we hope could
also tell when people are physically
interacting it's a young couple living
with the lodger focused on this PC or a
diagram over here we can tell that the
red and blue samples are closer together
that's a couple who are not genetically
related but who are living together and
sharing more microbes because their
physical interaction hopefully not with
the lodger the logit does indeed show a
significantly differentiated microbiome
compared to young couple more similar to
the young couple veneers to anyone else
in our study because he's living in the
same space and sharing the microbial
cloud their noses are not
microbiologically similar because people
don't interact with their noses so
working with Time magazine we applied
this technique with the Department of
Justice to set up some crime scene
investigations that was the unfortunate
cover of our our issue a time but Jared
Hampton Marcel is my my awesome lab
manager and all-around guru he if you
ever want to know anything about DNA
extraction he's your man but he went
down to Florida because it's warm in the
winter and worked with the Florida PD on
and the their forensic team on setting
up a crime scene crime team we had a
professor's house from local University
his wife and their cat living in a house
they went away for like ten minutes and
two of the students were like an hour
and half so two of the students broke
into the house
and ransacked their fridge I've stole
their TV and they're in there for like
35 minutes and then they left okay we
went in with the PD because this
burglary happened and we swapped all the
surfaces the floor
sequence the microbiome on the floor and
on the surfaces we went then brought the
husband and wife and the cat back in and
sequence their microbiome from their
skin surfaces subtracted the residents
microbiome from what we found on the
floors and the surfaces so we had a
residual microbial fingerprint and then
we ran that microbial fingerprint
analysis against 8,000 people in our
database of skin microflora with also
with with the to students who have
burgled the house because we knew who
they were right we send them in and we
could identify the students with 99.6%
accuracy based on our 8,000 people the
microbe or fingerprint left over is
actually slightly better than using
their genotype if you just use you know
the standard genotype fingerprinting and
not whole genome sequencing so we are
very excited by that Department of
Justice is very excited about that and
they've funded us and JCP I and a few
other people to expand this into a large
studies to determine the potential of
utilizing this kind of microbial
forensics in order to detect crimes in
the coming century and if you think
about the number of people that are put
in prison on the basis of bite marks or
hair fibers or clothing fibers which are
[ __ ] for detecting anything
accurately this might be a valuable
addition to forensic teams catalog of
tools in order to get the right the
wrong people in jail you know I mean but
the get the baddies in jail and get the
keep the goodies out of jail I just want
to point this out finally cuz I got like
two minutes right maybe a minute I
mapped my microbial dynamics in our
house this is my family I don't give a
[ __ ] about IRB suck it
talking to roof and I'm even gonna go
worse this is my youngest son and let
them fire me he's my youngest son he's
microbially interacting with the bedroom
floor it was the only one that really
had a hand interaction with the bedroom
floor why because he's crawling around
on the floor right he was two years old
we did the study and so you can see
these weird little interaction to map
them when we had dogs into that mix dogs
significantly increase the microbial
distribution patterns of the of the home
they they increase the amount of sharing
between people my colleague Rob Knight
showed that if you have dogs in the home
you're more likely to share more
bacteria than if you don't have dogs and
we mapped out that interaction over six
weeks of daily analysis and you can see
that the dogs do indeed significantly
increase the diversity and diversity of
interactions what's it with my wife
maybe use this to rescue a dog from
Kentucky named captain Bo Diddley he's a
proper southern captain perrolli and he
has actually increased the microbial
diversity of our house only by a small
margin and our house is known of one but
it was significant compared to the time
periods before and so we think is it
important because if you introduce dogs
into a family's home when the child is
under the age of one they have a 13%
reduction in the likelihood of
developing asthma and work from
University of California San Francisco
has demonstrated the dog bacteria such
as lactobacillus when gavage into a
mouse's intestine can significantly
reduce the likelihood that Mouse having
an asthmatic attack okay so these
interactions all suggest that every
single one of you should go out and
rescue I repeat rescue not buy a dog as
soon as you possibly can and I'm gonna
end X I talked about toilets and stuff
and I got a bit carried away ba
but I would decide to point out we have
a new journal m-systems I mentioned it
anyone that's interested in microbial
systems biology and you you want to
publish in an awesome journal where you
get rapid decisions bla bla bla then you
can publish in our journal we have a
great line of senior editors from across
the board of kind of the research areas
and we have over a hundred and ten
editors most hundred and ten editors are
the ones that will handle and make
decisions for every manuscript so you'll
get fast rapid decisions and I am on
every single one of those hundred ten
editors to make sure that the reviewers
give out reviews in the timeframe which
they have agreed upon so no more waiting
around and I've been a senior editor is
me journal and environmental
microbiology and I understand pain so
this is my way of getting our pain
alright that's it thank you
90% reflux yes microbiome changer that
it's not based on the structure is based
on the composition so no not easily I
mean you could take a pickle microbiome
transplant and if you waited long enough
you replace your mic the concessional
might fly with somebody else's I
couldn't swallow a person it's possible
you could go for a short period time
where your skin is not just the surface
it's a deep contextual environment and
if i sterilize your hand right now
there's an alcohol way in three minutes
afterwards I'd be able to detect your
unique microbe is it bubble butt back
from the surface right so we've done
that study on a number of occasions
they're very very keen to know that
because you know the best thing about it
is yeah you might have to determine that
you're not very unlike to be able to
change your strain level differentiation
and unless you're wearing a hazmat suit
you're never going to be able to stop it
from shedding
even if you wear gloves it's constantly
leaving your body
yeah well okay so to be perfectly honest
I'm split between us I don't think it
should be done in in small children's
environments I'm sorry the question is
spraying antibiotic cleaning products
onto surfaces what impact about be
having on people's family man Terry
Terry Terry over here on the wall
so what we're most interested in is
trying to see if it affects camp okay
and we see no real implications between
health because I service you use these
things and then you and then you
interact with something you're picking
up a microphone your microbiome
resurfaces pretty fast we do know that
certain cleaning products into a
trickler son can have a potential impact
and then might have some hormonal impact
although that's still tenuous I don't
have any conflicts of interest related
companies to manufacture these things
but I would say that in infancy of
developing I think it's dangerous to
sterilize the environment as much as we
do I think we should actually be
increasing their interactions and we
work with our mission Hutterite families
yeah the our mission home and personal
fan family farms the kids always
interrupt the animals a Hutterites don't
only boys over the age of fourteen year
an album of farm they're both from the
same ancestral population they're both
you have a very similar lifestyle apart
from that one removal of a microbial
source and the Hutterites the Amish have
virtually no asthma in the population of
35,000 people we look at the Hutterites
have 30% has to be in there but their
population could be do something else
by some remarkable coincidence so I
would say increasing the biological
diversity in a world where we can
control pathogens through vaccines and
and control measures with our community
in our environment we should actually be
increasing our microbial diversity very
interaction with the natural world
rather deep asleep
opposite
yes you can
III have an autistic son so I'm slightly
biased in this respect my I obviously
believe that that there is a significant
link between microbial dysbiosis and the
child's gut especially early in life and
development of the brain and we we have
some evidence that haven't published yet
in rats to demonstrate this I'm lucky
affirm Sarkis mazmanian and Paul
Patterson out of Caltech has
demonstrated a significant link between
a model a mouse model of autism and the
addition of a probiotic in order to
alleviate that now what was a mouthful
of autism ask yourself the the Mongoose
racing very interesting geological
behaviour and physiological disturbances
which are very similar to what we see in
autistic children and the probiotic does
tend to alleviate those conditions so
they're moving for with a Phase two
trial now looking at its introduction
into a human population
so I I have hope that we can rebalance
people's systems I just want to point
out I'm side biased because my son is
perfect just the way he is and I
actually embraced neurological diversity
in our community in a way that I think a
lot of people are scared to do because
the the other is a little bit too
different and they don't like it maybe
academics this is the right audience to
talk about that way so I'm actually not
trying to kill my son and I'm gonna try
and change him for the world
I know there are the people who are
desperately in need of an improvement in
their quality of life yes
all right in any of them
what is the where's the signs that in
modifying microbiomes let me move out
humans for a second and into the soils
because I think that's an interesting
one I do have a conflict of interest in
this in the fact I have an interest in
gross sentía Matt Wong's Dean's company
which produces a probiotic to increase
your blood group all those kind of
describes out there you want big butts
make you higher in that instance we've
demonstrated that in order to actually
allow those bacteria that we introduced
into the soil of these plants to have a
significant policy we have to disrupt
the ecosystem to reduce the stable
associations between the existing
microbes the best way to do that from
our perspective is to add more carbon
different carbon substrates into the
soil system prior and it shakes up the
status quo and then you actually Pro
buyers who can think bamboos something
started takeover Matt doesn't want to
know that because then they're in the
soil and he doesn't have to add more of
his product which we're making pooris or
is that's not cool
ah theoretically the same is true for
human intestines or buildings or
wherever environmental interesting we
disrupt in the initial ecosystem and
then and an over layer it with a new one
people microbiome transplant works
exactly like that else tends to be a
little bit of hand way yes so I think
that's it's interesting that you say
that and I think that country will be
kind of disagree oh that's but that
contradicts with one of the things we're
doing with the hind castle right so I
think I agree with you that when you
have community it sort of sometimes hard
to push that equilibrium to a new state
yeah but yeah when you run that I'm
casting you're saying that these climate
variables are just going to change the
community to respond that new climate
instantly without the memory
while those those takes 30 years for it
to change right so I guess I'm saying
with the home calendar it takes you know
the climate is this it's gonna take 30
years that I could even to reach it
probably due to a change of plan
AIA diversity of in the above-ground
system well I guess I guess what I'm
going out with that that trending is an
inability to understand that variants
and the parameters of the system like
the human gut is never going to change
through an environment where it looks
like open ocean right you know car key
has to stay within certain balanced on
the main social systems are the same so
if I'm looking at a prairie
it has bounds of influence it's very
hard to go outside of those bounds we
don't necessarily know what those bounds
are but if we sample through the
parameter variance space we may be able
to capture those bounds and if we can
link the parameter variance base to what
the climate does to the microbial even
indirectly or directly we can have at
least an ability to predict the variance
in that in in the microbiome space the
structural space so the structural space
off that by providing the system within
the balance of reality by your right in
the fact that I can't play it comes back
150 years or even even a hundred years
is in the Nepal system one and actually
the actors but I'm only utilizing that
to demonstrate the opportunity to
identify how similar trends exists
irrespective of my ability to predicted
you will is trying to identify an
underlying current of of information
which predicts an emergent property
which I don't necessarily yet understand
and we can do that with reasonable
accuracy I think even if it's within the
bounds of predictability
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu